لذا ، دعونا نبدأ فقط
بمستحضرات التجميل من خلال تزيين
النافذة بالسترة
لأنك تعلم جيدًا
أن ملابس السيدة الأولى السابقة ميلانيا ترامب
حظيت باهتمام كبير عندما
ارتدت السترة لا أتذكر أنني
لا أهتم بك
أو شيء من هذا القبيل  كانت رسالتها ،
لذلك من الصعب عدم رؤية
الحب كنقطة مقابلة لذلك ،
أعني بصراحة تامة أنه قزم ، أعني أن
هذه هي طريقة جيل بايدن الهادئة
في ارتداء شيء
يتناقض بشكل مباشر مع الرسالة التي كانت
ميلانيا ترامب ترسلها
أيا كان  هذا يعني أنه لا أحد يعرف نوعًا
ما المعنى النهائي لذلك أنا حقًا
لا أهتم بك سترتك ولكن
بالتأكيد الرسالة من جيل بايدن واضحة
جدًا وفي نفس
المؤتمر الصحفي السريع الذي أجرته في وقت سابق
اليوم قالت إن الحب هو الرسالة
التي  نحاول الإرسال إلى بلدان أخرى
نريدهم أن يعرفوا أن أمريكا
تدعمهم أو
شيئًا بهذا المعنى ، لذا من الواضح
أنها تراسلها وهي أيضًا قد أضيف
امرأة دعاية جيدة جدًا من
أجل h  زوجي جو بايدن أعني أن هذا
هو الدور الذي لعبته
جيل وتولته لمدة أربعة عقود
أو أكثر.
كانت سترة الحب شيئًا
اختارت أن ترتديه اليوم